[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and Speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact on July 30 2016
American Luke Aikins became the first
person to jump from over four and a half
miles up without a parachute and lived
to talk about it in a stunt called
heaven Scent the 42 year old parachute
safety advisor leaped
25,000 feet to earth setting the world
record for the highest jump without a
parachute to accomplish this aikens had
to use the rushing air currents around
him to steer his body and safely land on
a special 100 by 100 foot net suspended
20 stories above the ground near Simi
Valley California
during the 2 minute freefall the
daredevil reached a hundred and 20 miles
an hour as he neared the ground with
only a second to go he quickly flipped
onto his back and landed squarely on the
net without injury Aikens who had
previously done 18,000 parachute jumps
said he'd been preparing for this stunt
for over two years
according to Associated Press just
before climbing into the plane to make
the jump safety officials ordered Aikens
to wear a parachute but Aikens argued it
would make his landing in the net more
dangerous and he'd never have a chance
to open it as the plane was climbing to
the drop zone he said the requirement
was lifted and he took off the chute did
you know the Bible says the devil once
tempted Jesus to jump from a lofty
height claiming angels would catch him
stay with his friends we're going to
learn more as we bring you this edition
of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred says that's one eight
hundred four sixty three seventy to
ninety seven let's get to our first
Bible question with pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastor Jean
Ross
will be going to the phones in just a
moment you're listening to Bible answers
live if you have a Bible question lines
are open and
good chance if you call now you'll get
your question on tonight's program and
it shouldn't take too long pick up the
phone for Bible questions 800 God says
that's eight hundred four six three
seven two ninety seven I am Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening listening frames and pastor Doug
let's begin the program with prayer dear
father once again we thank you that we
have this opportunity to study together
he asked for your guidance and the Holy
Spirit to be with those listening be
with us Father and lead us into a fuller
understanding of Bible truth for we ask
this in Jesus name Amen
amen I fasted I opened the program by
talking about this remarkable feat of
jumping out 25,000 miles high dozen feet
sorry yeah four miles that be the movie
25,000 feet out of the plane and not
having a parachute and then trying to
navigate to a well what probably seems
rather small when you're coming down
from that height at that speed but
landing in a net rather remarkable
that's like trying to dive into a cup of
water from the Empire State Building huh
and I did parachute once I did it they
they make you go tandem jumping and so I
was attached to someone but we did get
the feel of what it's like to freefall
and steer your way through the air and
we were up 13,000 feet and for every
13,000 feet he fall for approximately a
minute and I guess he was up where he
needed to start out with oxygen and
deliberately jumped without a parachute
you know during world war ii they say
you can never get me to jump out of a
plane with a parachute
unless the plane was on fire
but he jumped without a parachute and
you can be sure that he had practiced
that many times because he didn't want
to be just tempting the Lord I think he
had a wife and family he didn't want to
end his life so he's an instructor
18,000 jumps he'd practiced but then I
teased at the end of the fact by saying
did you know the Bible says the devil
tried to encourage Jesus to make a high
jump without a parachute you can read
about this in the book of Matthew
chapter 4 verse 5 during the three great
temptations that the devil Brock did to
Jesus it says then the devil took him
into the holy city and set him on the
pinnacle of the temple this is hundreds
of feet up and he said to him if you're
the Son of God throw yourself down and
now the devil quotes the Bible fruit is
written he'll give his angels charge
over you and in their hands that will
bear you up lest you dash your foot
against a stone here Satan is only
partially quoting Psalm 91 and of course
Jesus refused to fall for it he said it
is written you shall not tempt the Lord
your God and that when we are recklessly
risking our lives and tempting God well
you know the Bible says God is not
mocked what a man says he'll reap and if
we keep pushing the limits got will
often intervene and protect us yeah
there's many times he probably does bear
us up and save us from disaster but if
we keep pushing
we will experience the fruit of our risk
and
Jesus said no you don't needlessly risk
your life if something happens God can
intervene but you shouldn't tempt the
Lord and say Lord I'm gonna jump save me
yeah that's a very dangerous thing to do
now some people are facing temptation
all the time not just tempting the Lord
with unnecessary risk but you know we
meet with the devil every day just like
Jesus did how do you deal with
temptation maybe you're struggling as we
all do with temptation friends and you'd
like to know more about how can I have
the victory are there any tips any clues
to gaining the victory over temptation
Jesus of course used the Word of God we
prepared a book that has 12 of the most
Beeler biblical suggestions for how you
can successfully resist temptation maybe
you're needing freedom from some habit
this book has the tips and the guidance
to help you get a new life the book is
called tips for resisting temptation and
we'd like to give this to you for free
all you'll need to do is give us a call
on our resource phone number and the
number is
885 six seven four seven you can answer
the book called tips for resisting
temptation that number again is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
the phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven it's
800 God says for 63 72 97 well pastor
doc I think we're ready for our first
caller this evening and we have William
who is listening in New York William
welcome to the program are you today
Shalom everyone hi how are you doing
William I'm grading yourself it's hard
to get through this phone numbers first
time calling I tried to call several
times they've always been busy so this
time I said my clock would be alarmed
and made sure that I
got answered
yes yes yes my question was being a half
Jew like pastor Doug we have a tradition
with pretty much my tradition but it's
been a biblical thing where the tallit
says the fringes you know with the
commandment what he gave us but I just
want to want to ask Pastor Doug is him
being that half Jewish as well what he
thinks about the Jewish people like the
Messianic and I'm not talking about
Orthodox because we know the office of
you is still doing what is under the law
but why what Paul is talking about we
wearing cap or even on they are I say on
bought miss fur and everything else and
weddings we still use the core and stuff
like that but what he my question is
what do you think that what Paul was
talking about when a man should not
cover his head in prayer I mean Jesus
believed that use the tool even the time
a biblical times when he's here and
pretty much I believe everybody that was
Jewish I was covering their head yeah
that's a good question and you find that
in first Corinthians chapter 11 you know
in the Jewish tradition sometimes four
sacred occasions I know when I went to
the Wailing Wall I just went to my one
of my Jewish relatives got married and
they had a basket of yarmulkes is what
we call them for covering your head
during the wedding and yeah I have no
problem doing that it's supposed to be a
sign of humbling yourself when you're in
a sacred occasion for the presence of
God and
but you know it's different customs in
different countries you know now I was
actually in a church today and I wore a
baseball cap because it's raining here
in Northern California to the church
when I walked in the church I took my
hat off as a sign of respect and so in
different cultures they have different
customs that are just physically showing
a sign of respect and that's what I
think you're seeing alluded to there
where it talks about covering the head
in first Corinthians chapter 11 or
during prayer and most of what it says
there in first Corinthians 11 is
actually addressing women covering their
heads as opposed to men yeah and we know
that their hair is the covering pretty
much like when we go to a courthouse and
you know I'm Minister she and I watched
your show when I was growing up and your
testimony is like pretty much mine's the
only thing difference my dad known
planes and everything else my father
holds a garment district in New York
City mother was Jewish and come from
background I did pretty much everything
you did when I saw you someone that's a
while if I go and I always wanted to go
to one of your sermons that you would do
a seminar and it was hard for me to get
a contact I know you're a busy man but
it's like these questions that you bring
up I share with messianic believers and
I share with the people that worship on
the first first day of the week what
they call Sunday which we're supposed to
keep the Sabbath because you're teaching
is so amazing and I'm glad you call it
amazing fact it is so a blessing and you
know the truth shall set you free but we
have a course where I go to the
Messianic temple and I saw with my
Protestant you know Pentecostals you you
say you know because they have a sense
where you know we get to fellowship I
think when we get to the kingdom of God
we're gonna all be see we are going to
be saying one thing holy holy is the
Lord you know yes and I
this perspective is like they look at me
say why do you wear you know it's a boy
it was tradition well my mother's Jewish
background it's Kippur he says why you
still wearing the front design we have
this every Wednesday we go a Bible study
now do you know but pardon me for
jumping in William because we do have a
few other callers standing by but
when when you've got the fringes of
course on the garment and then you've
got the Orthodox Jews that will also not
cut their
their sideburns and
the corners of their beard you know
based on that verse but those are
actually a couple of different things
the fringes are supposed to be a sign of
loyalty to God and the law that the
priests wore I don't know that you know
we're required to wear the priestly
garments today there's nothing in the
New Testament that says that we're sort
of you know a nation of kings of priests
now but hey William I really appreciate
your call and your testimony sounds
amazing but though we've gotta go on to
some other callers so with that thank
you and we'll be happy to send you that
free offer we mentioned on the heart the
new heart yes again to receive our free
offer this evening call and ask for the
study guide called I love that
transforms and the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is the free resource
phone line and asked for the study guide
called a love that transforms will be
able to send it to anybody who calls and
asks a next call he's Paul and he's
listening in Orlando Florida Paul
welcome to the program well thank you
very much yeah welcome to my life too
Michael to you my question to you is
simply this when Noah built the ark by
faith and what God had told him and the
time came and the flood came and
he rose above in the water and all his
his household and all the animals were
in the ark and they survived and all the
other people near earth
didn't survive they died I want to know
in my own mind is God a murderer of
those people what's what's the
definition of murder
you kill them no that's not the
definition of murder if a policeman
shoots somebody that is you know harming
a child or threatening the life of
others is the policeman defined by the
culture as a murder or is he doing a job
of justice
well who are these people killing I'm
just saying I'm talking about the
definition of murder because murder is
not killing
did God did God murder these people
because I think he did no murder that's
what I'm trying to tell them or was God
responsible for judging them yes is that
murder no
because when you you know if someone is
executed for a crime
the person who performs the execution is
not a murderer when a soldier goes to
battle to defend the country and they
have to fire on the enemy to defend the
homeland are they murderers No so the
word murder is not the right word is
what I'm saying kill these people
well the people who were destroyed
before the flood have you read the story
what do you know why they were destroyed
just answer my question no I am
answering you I'm agreeing that God
judged them and they were executed and
it says the reason was the thoughts of
their heart were only evil and violence
filled the earth they were killing each
other and so as a judgment God wiped out
the civilization except those that
accepted mercy by coming to the ark so
yeah I'm not denying that God said I'm
gonna destroy man who I made and it says
it grieved God it says I grieve God at
his heart to do this but absolutely it
was a judgment not only then in the days
of Noah you know I'll freely admit the
Lord is gonna come and it says only
those who are ready for his coming in
the future will be spared but there's a
great time of trouble coming where a
judgment is going to fall upon wicked
and violent people so yeah that's one of
the punishments for sin it's living for
self and
being evil there's a judgment for that
hope that helps a little bit and I
appreciate your call Paul you know we do
have a book that deals with judgment I'm
trying to think we don't have anything
specifically yeah we don't anything
specifically on the flood but we do have
a book called facing the judge it's
actually a study guide that deals with
the subject of judgment well they
happened to send this to anybody who
calls and asked the number to call his
808 three five six seven four seven you
can answer the study guide called facing
the judge again 808 three five six seven
four seven annex holy is Kimberly
listening in Idaho Kimberly welcome to
the program
hello thank you my question is is it
okay for a Christian to celebrate
Halloween and if not why not
well you know if we were to ask the
question a little differently is there a
holiday among the cultural holidays that
it would not be appropriate to celebrate
if there is a holiday that would not go
well with Christian theology and
practice I would think it would be
Halloween just because first of all the
history of it it kind of grows out of a
druid priests
practice in England you know the the
Catholics called it All Saints today
where they would pray to the dead Saints
and that kind of combined with some of
the other cultures and you know even if
you look around you see people dressing
up like witches I just heard their
outlying clown costumes now or something
because that people have been dressing
up as clowns and doing seedy things and
but you know ghosts and devils and and
some of my recognizer homeless people
might dress up like an angel but yeah
the idea if you give me a treat or I'm
gonna sabotage your home with eggs
that's what we did when we were kids if
we do a trick if they didn't give us a
treat and you know just there's so many
trappings of Easter Kimberly that I'm
sorry of Halloween that are rooted in
paganism but you know I don't think a
Christian should celebrate it you know
if people knock on your door I don't
recommend you open the door and shout
that I don't believe in Halloween slam
the door
you know might give them something
redeemable or profitable Dennis must
love Halloween all these kids come away
with
cavities
anyway I don't know if that's answering
your question I
think so I just
everything do you think they are still
based on us
I've heard that arts
you know human sacrifices and things
that happen on Halloween do you believe
that still happens
celebrating it or if they're going to
for treating are you participating and
yeah I
yeah I well I you know I know that back
in the days of Harry Houdini there are a
lot of people's that participated in
seances especially in Halloween it's
sort of like a hi day for you know
satanic worshippers
so whether or not there's human
sacrifice still going on well I I
haven't heard of that it may be I know a
lot of devious things happen during that
time usually not a great not a lot of
great blessings come out of Halloween
they tell parent people stay close to
your kids and make sure that you don't
you know take fresh fruit from people
because it could be poison I mean it
seems like there's a lot of stuff to
worry about so yeah I it's one holiday
I'm not real excited about as a
Christian and I don't know that we can
justify it hey I hope that helps a
little you know a matter of fact we have
yeah yeah we have a web site that is
called death truth and I think there's a
segment in there it says what about
Halloween usually this time of year we
put it up at the front well we have a
website called ghost truth as well yeah
that deals with that same subject
specific related yeah to Halloween and
this time of the year again just go to
the website take a look at ghost truth
calm there's a lot of video there and
good Bible study content that I think
you'll enjoy our next Kohli's eden is
listening in michigan ed welcome to the
program you're on Bible answers live
how can we help
in your question tonight oh yeah yeah I
I heard some stuff in the well anyways
as I was reading Genesis chapter 6 and
verse 8
I was wondering how when God said he is
going to destroy the human race
how how could you how can a person
even though your son Grace and the Lord
how can
you
compromise or I don't know that's not
very good word compromise but how can
how come God didn't just destroy even
the eight and just think the ark or
whatever you know you mean how come he
showed grace to Noah well that's why I
mean if you look at the next verse right
after it says Noah found grace for the
Lord it says this is the genealogy of
Noah Noah was a just man perfect in his
generations Noah walked with God and so
you know there's a connection between
Noah finding grace and Noah choosing to
walk with God and and be a just man and
perfect in his generations he was a
godly man and
so you know the Lord picked him to be
the one through whom the human race
would be repopulated and to be the
vehicle of saving
no is actually a type of Christ yeah you
still there in
are you still there yeah does that make
sense what wasn't there in another place
of the like Moses talking to God and God
was not
happy with the human race - well there
was a place guy
there was a place where God was going to
destroy the children of Israel there at
the golden calf and moy Moses interceded
for them and you know God through the
intercession of Moses spared the people
there was a judgement among some of them
that were the chief instigators but and
then there's you know before the flood
it says in Genesis chapter 6 there's a
day when the are the sons of God saw the
daughters of men they were fair and took
wives that's talking about also the
intermarriage between the children of
Seth and the children of Cain and how
that they kind of gave up their
commitment to God but yeah I hope that
helps a little bit and you know I think
we do have a book speaking of grace it's
called the riches of His grace and we'll
be happy to send you a free copy of that
in the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask to the book
called the riches of His grace again
eight hundred eighty three five six
seven four seven that is the resource
phone line and if you have a Bible
question the phone line here to the
studio is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven a next
holy is Sharon listening from West
Virginia Sharon welcome to the program
thank you
and your question well my question is in
the book of Revelation chapter one verse
7 it talks about the special
resurrection of those who pierced Jesus
and that's before the general
resurrection of the wicked but I've just
heard recently I've been told that there
is also going to be a special
resurrection of some righteous people
and
the people who have told me this said
that it comes from John 5 where Jesus
says that the hour is coming when all
who are in the graves will hear his
voice and come forth and then Daniel
chapter 12 says that many
who sleep in the dust will come forth
and they say what Daniel is talking
about is a special resurrection of
people who lived in the time of the
third angels messages after
1844 and this is the first time that
I've heard anything like that and I'm
wondering have you heard this
yes and how you feel about it yeah the
well first of all for our listeners let
me just explain what we're talking about
here I remember when I first heard that
there was going to be two resurrections
it's prai's me I thought that when the
Lord came there's just one big general
resurrection and everybody gets lined up
and he separates the sheep from the
goats and some fall off the precipice
into boiling sulfur and brimstone and
others go off to glory but Jesus
actually said and you can find this in
Revelation 20 the first there's a first
in a second resurrection and even in
John 5:28 where you just quoted the
hours come in which those are in the
graves will hear his voice and come
forth those that have done good
resurrection of life those that have
done evil resurrection of condemnation
two different resurrections if you want
to know which is which it says the dead
in Christ rise first
this is speaking generally
that you know the ground and great
multitude of the righteous will rise
when Jesus comes and at the end of the
1,000 years it says the rest of the Dead
don't live till the thousand years are
finished that's the second resurrection
of the Lost but there are a few
exceptions when we're talking about
resurrections the Bible does say of
course Elijah was resurrected
didn't die he went to heaven early well
that's an exception it's a rare
exception you went to heaven in a fiery
chariot Enoch walked with God and God
took him he did not die Moses was
resurrected and you find that in the
book of Jude that's a special
resurrection of Moses Jewish tradition
says it was three days after he died and
then at the second coming of Jesus
Christ said to Caiaphas the high priest
hereafter you will see the Son of man
coming in the clouds of heaven so
there's evidence there that K IFAs and
those who were guilty of crucifying and
condemning Jesus they're kind of brought
up in a special resurrection of judgment
to show a look this is the one you
condemned he is the king now he's the
judge and you're the plaintiff yeah and
then there's some who in the last days
have proclaimed the second coming and
they may have died before the second
coming but they wanted to tell everyone
he was coming soon the Lord's gonna
bring them up in time to see him come
and see the final events and so this is
what I think
you're talking about Sharon and and hope
that makes sense
are you with me I'm with you there's a
lot of static and I could hardly hear
what you were saying yeah we hear the
static - there's I don't know if it's
rain here in California we've had some
flooding but so we brought your volume
down just to deal with the static we do
have that the study guide that talks
about one of the actually a website on
death talks about the resurrections
right there if you just go to treat
about death or death truth that com same
words right we have a study guide also
called
thinking about the study guide past that
I'm dealing with the second coming
ultimate deliverance yes and of course
that talks about the resurrection when
Jesus comes again again we'll be able to
send it to anybody who calls and asks
the phone line for our resource line is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can call ask for the
study guide called ultimate deliverance
it's all about the Second Coming you can
go to the amazing facts website death
truth calm and you can also read about
when the power of the grave is broken at
the second coming of Christ the glorious
resurrection absolutely thank you for
calling I think we've got 30 seconds
before we take our break in and it's
probably not going to be up I hear the
music in the background don't don't go
away friends there's more calls more
questions and a matter of fact we even
have lines open if you have a Bible
question pick up the phone give us a
call I'm just gonna take a brief break
here in a moment that number again 800
god says eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and the let your
friends know again another 30 minutes of
amazing facts Bible answers live be
right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
nice a curious thing I mean just when
things seemed under control wham you hit
with something new your marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
the jobs great and then it's gone and so
is your life savings you feel healthy
any doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next you could look to the stars
they don't have the answers
the prophecy study Bible by amazing
facts this Bible special its 27 personal
study guides leave you on a
life-changing journey through God's Word
to discover real answers to life's
questions from health and relationships
to family and the future hopes in here
get your amazing facts prophecy study
Bible today by calling
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at one eight hundred seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven now let's join pastors doug
batchelor and john ross for more Bible
answers live
we are back listening friends to Bible
answers live and if you joined along the
way it is just as it sounds it's a live
international interactive Bible study
and we're glad you're tuning in if you
have a Bible question you know we got
friends listening on satellite radio all
over the country driving down the road
now is a chance to give us a call 800
god says eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and I am still Doug
Batchelor my name is Jean Ross and we
gonna go
you know I was fiddling with my
microphone yeah that's why I can't do
two things at the same time alright
we've got Steve listening from Temecula
California did I say that right yeah
okay Steve welcome to the program hi hey
doing great and your questions my hair
yes you on the air
okay I'm sorry my question about
Revelation the beginning it says at the
time of his hand and I come shortly and
right therefore the things you have seen
the things which are the things that are
about to happen and then he asked John
to write seven letters to the seven
churches in Asia Minor telling them
about this
tribulation that's coming and I'm a
little confused because you know I've
been down I've studied some prayer ISM
and I've studied you know the future is
and I'm little confused about it
the question I have is basically
you know if God's calling that the time
is about happen then and it doesn't
happen then is kind of misleading em I
mean III don't understand I guess any
clarification good I don't want to you
know I don't be blasphemous and don't
think it's okay to ask questions God God
wants us to seek he says come let us
reason together if you're reverently
wanting to understand and something
doesn't make sense it's tell the Lord
but first of all I'm glad to hear you
say you mentioned predator predator ISM
and then you mentioned futurism you know
they're the third of what used to be the
most popular view of history of prophecy
was called his store ism and I am a
historian my interpretation which means
some people think everything in
Revelations all in the past it's all
happened it all happened in the first
100 years roughly of the Christian era
futurists believe that like from
Revelation 4 on is all in the future
the historically when John said the time
is at hand are actually Jesus is the
time is it had that he's saying these
prophecies are going to begin being
fulfilled now and they'll carry on to
the second coming it covers the panorama
of history that's what we believe in the
seven churches you have the seven ages
of the church seven phases the church
has gone through stages from the time of
John until the second coming the last
one being Laodicea a lukewarm Church
just before Jesus comes and the series
of prophecies in Revelation and this is
really pastor Ross's favorite book you
get the seven trumpets in seven seals
and the seven churches they're all
covering different aspects of the
history of the battle between good and
evil from the time of John the first
coming till the second coming indeed
until we're in heaven because that's how
the book closes so we have a Bible study
series that explains the historic view
if you'd like to see that we'd be happy
to share with you for free
okay that's a long answer I'm sorry
I understand that historical music but
he's asking seven natural turkeys or no
well he did do you know keep in mind the
Bible is an incredible book in that
historical things happened but then they
had a kind of a prophetic meaning give
you just an example Abraham went down to
Egypt with Sarah the Pharaoh took his
wife and Abraham said no you can't have
her she's my wife and then the Pharaoh
sends him out of Egypt with great
rewards
years later that happened to Abraham's
people they went down to Egypt God took
Israel like his slave and
God was forced the Pharaoh rather took
them and the Pharaoh was forced to let
them go and sent them out they went out
with great substance and so the story of
Joseph is a true story but it's also the
story of Jesus who is betrayed by one of
the twelve and sold for the price of a
slave and Joseph was in prison but he
came out alive to rule I mean there's
all these allegories in the Bible and so
the seven churches the letters the seven
churches they were letters to those
seven churches but they have a much
bigger prophetic meaning because it's
it's a prophetic book
expecting
a time of tribulation for them and then
that actually happens in the first
century there was a lot of
persecution that happened yeah Jesus
said there would be a great tribulation
around the time that the temple was
destroyed in 70 AD but many said they'll
also be one near the end of time he said
developing wars and rumors of wars but
the end is not yet in other words don't
think every war a rumor of war means
it's the end of the world there have
been lots of wars from the time of
Christ till now and then he gives us
what the signs are till the end you'd
enjoy this prophecy series I'm just real
tempted to dive in and try and explain
it all in one phone call but I can't do
that so yeah pastor also give you the
number and you ought to sign up for the
amazing fact study guide series the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you can
just ask to enroll in the free math
facts study guide series again that's
883 five six seven four seven will
actually send you some lessons in the
mail and you'll be able to go through
them and send back the answer sheets and
we'll grade that and send you the next
set of lessons and it's absolutely free
so again one more time the number is 883
five six seven four seven you can ask
for the amazing facts Bible School and
we'll be happy to sign up anyone who
calls and asks let's see how next Holies
Rick and he's listening on Ontario
Canada Rick welcome to the program
hello these are you there you're the
yeah we're here you're there we're alive
and you're on the air with my oh my
goodness well thank you for taking my
call mm-hmm and you know my question is
if we had a global flood how did the
Kangaroos end up making it to Australia
like did as far as I know they can't
swim so I didn't know they couldn't swim
but I wasn't thinking that they swam all
the way matter of fact not just the
Kangaroos but Australia I've been there
several times is a very unique country
in that they've got a lot of marsupial
creatures you don't find anywhere else
on the planet I do believe that
following the flood that all these
animals came out of the ark and they
began of course the multiply and and
they were walked and hopped and crawled
in all different directions and began to
populate different parts of the globe
and there is a pretty widely accepted
theory both in science and even in the
Bible that there was some continental
drift going on that there was an ice age
that there were areas where there were
land bridges but as some of the ice
melted it too covered some of those
areas and that Australia was one of the
first places some of the animals
principally marsupials went to and then
they were separated by seas and I just
don't think the continental drift you
know right after the flood I think it
was happening very quickly kind of like
ice moving on water
not quite that quick but you know a lot
faster than the the millions of years
per inch they say now so I believe that
some of those animals were isolated
there and
there's actually verse and I don't
remember where it is passed Ross where
it says in the days of Peleg that the
cod the earth was divided mm-hmm it's in
Genesis so it's some time after the time
of Noah so after the flood there was
some kind of division happening in the
earth and that is Genesis chapter 10
verse 25 yeah so that's that's my story
and I'm sticking to it Rick okay well
thanks very much I appreciate your input
anyway alrighty thanks a lot bye-bye
annex holy is Roy listening from Des
Moines Iowa Roy welcome to the program
doing well thank you for calling hey
thank you for every my first time we
call it I was thinking I'll try to get
in I would try to get in there cutting
is first time I got in it's wonderful to
hear you talk to your program each week
so I had a question for you what I was
wondering I've heard a lot about the
Fallen Angels I think that's in
Revelations I mean in Genesis they talk
about and one of the scriptures I'm not
sure quite words at but they talk about
the fallen ones that lift up onto women
and God allowed him to interbreed with
the
women
now I don't see nothing that he cut that
off he flooded all that off at the flood
but Satan could he have carried his
bringing back
yeah let me let me take a stab at that
that is that theory and it is a theory
is based upon a verse there in Genesis
chapter 6 where it said when the sons of
God saw the daughters of men that they
were fair they took them wives of all
they chose and some have assumed that
these sons of God must have been angels
and since good angels would not disobey
God and marry people they must have been
bad or fallen angels you hear about
fallen angels in revelation 17 Genesis
doesn't really talk about fallen angels
the phrase sons of God has used three
ways in the Bible sometimes it does talk
about angels most of the time the word
sons of God is talking about believers
if you look in first John chapter 3
eret says behold what manner of love the
father has bestowed on us that we should
be called sons of God so believers are
called sons of God the sons of God in
Genesis were the descendants of Adam
through his good son Seth Adam had a son
that went bad named Cain they separated
early on after Cain killed Abel he went
off took his wife went off by himself
were married one of his sisters they
raised a generation that was in
rebellion to God they were called the
the people of men the sons of God are
the ones who believed in God they were
adopted and redeemed but when the
believers began to intermarry were the
unbelievers everything went south as
they say and then the flood king these
were not fallen angels that intermarried
with people now I do have a book I'll
send you a free copy that specifically
deals with this question and it's called
who are the sons of God it's actually
aliens or adopted who are the sons of
God but we'll be happy to send you if we
copy that if you'd like Roy yeah
[Music]
the Nephilim yeah the Nephilim were the
children that came and they believe they
were giants
and there's something happens there
whatever you've got two people groups
that are separated for a while and then
they get together and marry you have
what they call genetic vitality and you
know whenever you in breed and one
family for a long time you're gonna have
problems but you know as far back in
time I mean after the flood if you keep
going in time all the way down to the
time of Moses and Joshua in the time of
Judges it speaks of giants entire tribes
of Giants living up in the mountains
area and David and David of course hear
the story of Goliath so there were
giants and probably families that were
known for their height and they size
even back in the time of Israel the
Exodus yeah so yeah these weren't fallen
angels that the children of the sons of
God of the daughters of Cain you're
right and that you may ask a good
question if angels could interbreed with
humans just because God destroyed him in
the flood what would prevent them from
doing it now that's why we don't think
they were angels good question we'll
send you that free book on who are the
sons of God just call the number then
I'm gonna call is 808 three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called who are the sons of God
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks again eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
the resource phone line and the phone
number yet of the studio with a Bible
question he's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven die amethyst
listening from Pennsylvania Diana's
welcome to the program
good evening pastors evening
my question is that is an order to eat
clean meat does it have to be kosher
well the idea of kosher meat kosher is
sort of a more modern Hebrew wised term
I think I made up a word
it's kind of me to come from the Hebrew
culture
that an animal was to be killed and
butchered a certain way now biblically
not only were there certain animals that
you could not eat the ones you could eat
had to be killed where their throats
were cut and all the blood was drained
out because they were never to eat blood
and you'll see that command not only in
the Old Testament in Leviticus you see
it in Acts chapter I think it's 15 or
they command them to abstain from blood
if I'm not mistaken so new an Old
Testament it says you can take blood
that means if they were gonna eat an
animal it had to be butchered a clean
animal it had to be butchered in a
kosher way meaning that it had to be
clean now the rules about kosher food
have expanded the rabbi's have expanded
on those rules over time and you know
there are even some rabbis would say if
they they could even take some Pig and
butcher it emotionally now that I
there's only a few of those out there
that but you know technically that would
be unclean no matter how you butchered
it so anyway their rabbis have kind of
some of them expanded those rules and it
kind of turned into a racket you know
you had to have a rabbi bless your
butcher shop or you couldn't buy your
food there now the verse you're
referring to is acts 15 verse 20 that
talks about abstaining from blood things
that are strange yeah
there you now we do have a study guide
called God's free health plan deals with
the biblical principles of health and
that we'll be able to say this to me
tonight yeah absolutely Dianna thought
anybody wanting to learn more just give
us a call on our resource phone
Nightline that's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the study guide called God's
free health plan we'll be able to send
that to anyone who calls an S and next
call e is slushy listening from Florida
slushy welcome to the program hi how are
you doing dude well thank you for
calling
thank you I listen to my husband
it's
amazing oh well thanks for glad you
called my question to me is there
anything in the Bible that
specifies any difference between burial
and cremation
good question yeah we've had that from
time to time
typically in the Bible people were
buried and the reason for that is it was
believed that man made in the image of
God even in death because he reflected
the image of God it should be treated
with the remains should be treated with
respect
and you know you look at the patriarchs
Abraham Isaac Jacob Joseph they all were
carefully buried in the case of Jacob
and Joseph they were embalmed and buried
and
you know they there's only a couple of
occasions where someone was burned and I
think that was
Jonathan and Saul his father is because
their bodies had been mutilated and so
the people of Jay both guilty had burned
their bodies and if a person's burned
you know a lot of Christians were burnt
at the stake for their faith in
different countries that doesn't prevent
God from resurrecting them but typically
the Christians were buried now I
understand economically a cremation is a
lot more affordable and as people
multiplying grave spaces getting much
more expensive and in sparse and people
think it's C you know more
environmentally friendly thing to do to
do a cremation and certainly God you
know can resurrect a person because it
says ashes to ashes dust to dust if you
die and you're buried if you're not
involved you'll eventually turn into the
elements of the earth I don't mean to be
rough and how I say that but
but you know I've just always believed
biblically you'll see the example they
were buried no commandment anywhere that
says thou shalt not cremate hey you see
what I'm saying it's all you've got is
the example
circumstantial evidence is what we have
hey thank you very much appreciate your
call I next holy is let's see we have
constant Constantine listening from
Buffalo New York
Constantine welcome to the program
Constantine you there oh
hi you're on the air
[Music]
yeah give me well you know some of the
Catholic priests wear the the skull cap
and of course the Orthodox Jews do
different groups of Orthodox Jews much
we're much bigger broad hats you'll see
them wearing you know tall hat or
different kinds of hats but the whole
idea of the wearing of the hat in
connection with the sacred services was
you know as a sign of humbling
themselves in the presence of God
covering their head
it's it's basically a tradition I don't
know of any command in the Bible that
says you know you should cover your head
Aaron when he went in before the Lord to
minister had a miter a special hat that
he wore but it didn't look like if you
look at any of the paintings of the the
ancient Levitical priests they were a
tall hat they didn't wear a little it's
kind of like a baseball cap without the
rim on it a yarmulke that's what we
called him growing up
yeah so both in both cases for both some
of the Jews and even the Catholic
priests it's supposed to be a sign of
humility and the presence of God do you
want to be humbling yourself and that's
where it's drawn from
okay hey thank you appreciate your
question Constantine we had two
questions on the the heads tonight my
next Foley's Renee listening from New
Jersey Renee welcome to the program
my question is about believers or
according to the Bible believers in
Christ Jesus are only supposed to marry
other believers
now that's my understanding do you have
a scripture or two that points to that
for me yeah
Jesus said you know unless two walk
together unless two or agree they can't
walk together and Paul tells us and I
think pastor Ross is looking this up
right now that you should not be
unequally yoked together it doesn't make
sense for a believer why would someone
who believes that God is the most
important thing and I want to serve God
and I want to be I want to be with God
why would they deliberately marry
someone that doesn't believe that
you're the whole foundation for their
life is different I mean it's one of the
most elementary things you would want to
have in common with someone that you
marry now if you get here in a country
where they got an arranged marriage you
may not have a choice but you got a
choice man I never want to marry some of
the belief completely differently the
verse you're referring to second
Corinthians chapter 6 verse 14 yea and
second Corinthians chapter 6 and verse
14 do not be unequally yoked together
with unbelievers for what Fellowship has
righteousness with lawlessness and what
communion has light with darkness and
just all through the Bible you've got
the example of God telling his people do
not marry the daughters of other nations
do not marry the unbelievers or people
that serve other gods because they will
turn the hearts of your sons and
daughters away from me and you may
remember the story of Solomon it says
and Solomon loved many women he married
daughters of the Moabites and the
ammonites and the and all these
i'ts and and then as a result it says
they drew his heart away from God and so
usually if a believer marries an
unbeliever they kind of level out and
they come someone compromises their
faith along the way very rarely does the
believer completely and only influence
the unbeliever sometimes the unbeliever
influences the believer and they stop
going to church so you always want to
marry within your faith and someone's
gonna ask me someday what about marrying
someone from another denomination
doesn't matter if you're marrying the
same denomination I'm not gonna answer
that you're gonna ask it by the way we
do have a book on marriage divorce and
remarriage and talks about marrying
within your faith in there and we'll
give that book away for free to anybody
who calls and ask the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask to the
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage again 880 three five six
seven four seven and the book is called
marriage divorce and remarriage
an ex collie is hosi Hosea listening
from Manhattan New York Hosea welcome to
the program
was the yeah Hosea are you on the air
good a
[Music]
biblical reason for the special
resurrection well one of the reasons
would be when Jesus was being tried he
told the high priests and the Jewish
Council that he said I'm telling you
when they said you know we adjure thee
by the Living God are you the son of God
Jesus said verily I say unto you he said
now I said hereafter you will see the
Son of man coming and that's in Matthew
20 Matthew 27 mm 26 or 27 I think we're
at the trial of Christ and so that's one
statement and then it does say in
Daniel chapter 12 many of them that
sleep sleep in the dusty earth shall
awake some to everlasting life and some
to shame and everlasting contempt some
will be raised for shame and then in
Revelation 1 it says he's coming with a
cloud those also that pierced him will
see him that's Matthew chapter 26 and
verse 64 okay thank you very much 664 so
there are a few verses on that Hosea and
hopefully that helps we do have our
study guide that talks about the second
coming and we'll send you a free copy of
that absolutely we actually have a
website brand-new called rapture choose
dog combed and deals of this take a look
at the website rapture truth calm let me
say it one more time rapture truth calm
I forgot all about that it's the first
time we've told anybody that's right
it's brand-new and there's a magazine
that goes with that you're gonna want to
see as well listening friends we as you
can tell are going to be segwaying out
of the program don't change the dial yet
because we've got another amazing fax I
know that you're going to enjoy God
willing we'll take some more calls study
with
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing fax a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
did you know this boat could share the
gospel with 20,000 people or a car like
this one could reach 10,000 Souls
seeking hope in Jesus if you have a
vehicle you're not using and would like
to reach hearts for the kingdom of God
prayerfully consider donating your
vehicle to amazing facts today it's easy
to turn your unneeded car boat RV the
motorcycle even ATVs and jet skis into a
soul-winning vehicle for Christ and get
a tax deduction
amazing facts we'll arrange to pick up
your vehicle and provide you with a
tax-deductible receipt the proceeds from
the resale will be used to share God's
truth with millions of people around the
world
don't leave your vehicle in the garage
collecting dust use it to transform
lives through amazing facts contact us
today and let us help turn your car boat
RV or motorcycle into live saved for
Christ
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF ag0 RG and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]
hi friends this is pastor Doug Batchelor
would you like to hear an amazing fact
more and more of the world is turning
now to natural forms of energy to try
and find their power and they're
resorting to things like the wind farm
that we have here in Jamaica at wick
ttan you know I remember years ago my
wife and I going to visit the Big Island
of Hawaii and we were amazed that all
the potential there for natural power
what they weren't using it there at the
south part of the island there was
volcanic activity you can make
geothermal power there if you went to
why amia the wind was constantly blowing
but they had no windmills there if you
went over to Kona Sun always shines
solar electric but they didn't have very
much solar electric there and if you
went to Hilo it was always raining
hydroelectric and in spite of all that
potential for power there on the Big
Island of wife they were powering the
island back then where the dirty diesel
generators made me think about how we
sometimes waste the power of God's
Spirit that he's making available to us
and each of us can have that spirit if
we simply ask you can read in Zechariah
chapter Tim what do we do ask of the
Lord rain in the time of the latter rain
and he will send flashing clouds Jesus
also said in the book of Liberty if you
then being evil know how to give good
gifts to your children how much more
will your Father in Heaven give the Holy
Spirit and to them that ask when you
look in the book of Acts when the Holy
Spirit was poured out it says there was
a sound of a mighty rushing wind and
that power that launched the church back
then and still power your life today
friends so why don't you ask him
[Music]
for over 50 years amazing faxes shared
the wonderful news of salvation and
provided millions of Bible resources to
people all over the world we built
churches in India proclaim God's Word in
China and have sent free Bible studies
around the globe today's program and
three resources were made possible by
our ministry partners caring individuals
like you if you've been blessed by
amazing tracts would you please consider
partnering with us to reach others with
the Bible truth your financial support
today will help keep programs like this
on the air so the blessings you've
received can be shared with others to
find out more about becoming a ministry
partner please visit our website at
amazing facts dot foe RG
[Music]